Now remember that when we look at a mass on an inclined plane or a hill,
we break its weight into perpendicular and parallel components.
This parallel component is mg sin α.
That's the force that's kind of bringing the car down the hill,
that would tend to bring the car down the hill.
But we want the car to go up the hill.
This is the force that we have to combat, that we have to oppose.
Now, the slick way to solve this problem is to say that power is equal to force times velocity.
That's an equation that Jonathan showed you in one of the previous problem sets.
Well, our force is just mg sin α, and our velocity is 25 km/h.
If we plug in m of 2000, g of 10, α of 10 degrees, and a velocity of 25--
we need to convert that to m/s.
We're going to use this value of 6.94 m/s.
I get a power of 24100 W.
If you had a different solution, you should go to the forums and share it with your classmates.